j'ai mis en place cette société donc
j'ai fait un peu parler de moi sous les
réseaux sociaux ils ont commencé à me
contacter moi j'attendais d'eux trois
appels
j'attends des dizaines mais quand je
suis arrivé à deux sans appel je me suis
dit maintenant il ya un problème
donc du coup j'ai fait deux sauts à
mettre en place cette société a levé en
chaque personne qui m'a appelé pour
savoir qu'est ce qu'il nous a cherchés
qu'est ce que le désirez et certains
désireux de rencontrer du monde avec qui
parler vous savez j'ai un peu de leur
solitude
et puis voilà moi j'ai mis en relation
jeunes organisent des événements pour
eux
moi j'apporte mon aide à ces gens quand
c'est pour monter une prise faire des
placards une petite rénovation peinture
c'est facile il n'y a pas de souci mais
au fur et à mesure les deux modes
deviennent exorbitants et justement
parfois ça donc moi pour pouvoir porter
mieux à ces gens donc j'ai mis en ligne
cette can notamment pour faire des
rénovations d'appart d'habitat pour
améliorer les situations déjà se sentir
mieux chez soi c'est déjà quand même
exclure une part de soufre dans la
solitude mais il y en a d'autres qui
n'ont pas n'ont pratiquement pas grand
chose donc qui ont parfois le water
boucher qui n'ont pas de réfrigérateurs
qui stocke tout dans un congé qui
mettent des glaçons qu'un peu mais le
lendemain matin de trois jours après il
ya plus de glaçons d'orsay pour
permettre au moins à ces gens d'avoir
une autre situation de vie améliorée
déjà le quotidien pour apporter déjà un
peu de joie et ce peu de joie va déjà
diminué la solitude pour pouvoir encore
apporter mieux par rapport à ce que j'ai
fait pour eux pour les mises en relation
pour les sorties et tout pour qu'il
puisse déjà partir dans une mentalité de
notre condition mentale être plus est
déjà sur un point déjà partir de chez
soi
heureux s'est déjà montré un autre
visage à l'extérieur si je pars de chez
moi avec une tristesse dans la rue ou
bien même dans une sortie ou bien parce
que moi je vais organiser pour eux la
tristesse va s'en aller mais elle va
prendre du temps à s'évaporer donc c'est
tout ça